I'll tell you right now there are
companies that are prospering and let me
tell you why they're prospering a
prospering because they have leaders
with the anatomical attributes to pull
it off they're stepping up and they're
leading now the other companies and
we're dealing with both kinds out there
Hoshino have a spine there yeah that
we're dealing with both kinds of
companies out there that they're they're
leading well or their leaders are
complete pansies and they have stepped
back and their legal department and
their bean-counters are making their
decisions yep that's right and when your
legal department and your bean-counters
make the decisions in your company it's
just a matter of time before you die
you're on your way out of business at
that point and I would say those people
aren't actually leading you're not a
title you can have a title that says I'm
a big shot but like you said if you
don't have the spine and have the
courage to make a hard decision when
it's not popular when it's not socially
acceptable 100 percent of your decisions
someone will disagree with and so when
you look at what his leadership really
mean it's going first on the hard things
it's easy to go first when it's popular
it's easy to say I'll be a leader when
we're going to get ice cream let me buy
but when you're swimming upstream
culturally you're swimming upstream
even inside your organization not
everybody's excited about where we're
going and you have to shape the vision
for your team you've got to shape the
vision for your vendors you got to shape
the vision for your customers and in
this country right now what we need is
leadership and we need business owners
and entrepreneurs to step up and say
we're bringing the economy back we're
doing it we're gonna figure out how
we're not being reckless about it but we
got to get back to work this is our
country it's the time to fight for our
country and it takes leadership and the
real leaders are stepping up right now
and the fake leaders are sticking their
head in the sand and they won't be
leading tomorrow you know and let me
tell you real leaders lead while they're
afraid not in fear mm-hmm they lead
through the fear everyone has fear
especially when crap is coming against
your company your organization when
there's a medical catastrophe pandemic
that we've got on our hands there's fear
fear is real but you're going to do
something anyway and
not everyone's gonna want to do that and
that's fine that makes you not one of
the followers well you can figure it I'm
still gonna lead it that's right and you
got to decide are you are you wanting to
be effective or you want to be popular
because most the time you can't be both
and Dave you're talking about fear if
I'm honest pretty much every day I get
out of bed with some level of fear about
something but I don't stay in bed I
still have to lead somebody's got to
step up somebody's got to make a
decision and somebody's got to drive for
it and I think it's key that leaders
connect with their teams and say hey I
feel a little fear it's okay but we're
still gonna go let me tell you what just
gives you when you do throw back your
shoulders stick out your chest and lead
just freakin lead when you will just do
your job as a leader what happens is
that people can make a decision then if
they want to be on that train or not
okay I don't really care if you want to
be if you're not on my train I can deal
with that what I don't want is people on
my freakin train who are confused about
the direction the trains going this is
where we're going if you want to be a we
get your butt in gear this is what we're
doing if you want how to stick your head
up your assumptions and go do something
else that's fine
have at it baby but we're gonna be
opening and we're gonna be having an
event in Orlando called entree
Leadership Summit because we believe
America is ready to open and we no
longer believe the crap that has been
spread and the fear that has been spread
to the degree it has it are their real
concerns yes their real concerns but the
real concern right now is you have an
unpredictable environment and people
can't build a life on an unpredictable
environment when civil when civility
completely breaks down and Anarchy takes
over when people cannot predict the
direction that you're going because of
lawless lawlessness when they cannot
predict the direction that you're going
because you're such a pansy you won't
say where you're going because you're
afraid you're going to upset someone
then guess what guess what they don't do
any
you have to have a predictable
environment created by a leader setting
a standard for business transactions to
take place and for civilization to exist
that's right well and when you lead that
way you've got standards based on this
vision it was the American football
player Ralph marts and he said don't
lower your expectations to meet your
performance raise your level of
performance to meet the expectations and
you got standards hold your vendors to
the standards hold your team to the
standards it is that's what's best
trying to quit sucking our thumbs in
this whistle fide culture it is time for
some of you that call yourselves leaders
to get your butts in gear and start
leading again